-Welcome back, everybody.
We're talking to one of
our favorites, the one and only
Tyler Perry.
Come on now.
I want to talk about your new
movie, "A Jazzman's Blues."
You wrote and directed the this.
It's getting great reviews,
by the way.
-Can you imagine a Tyler Perry
movie getting great reviews?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
What is that like for you?
Do you go like --
Do you read the reviews?
-I never read them.
I haven't read them in the past.
But Oprah called me up.
She said, "Tyler, have you read
the review from 'Variety'?"
I was like, "No."
She said, "No, no, no,
you need to read it."
I was like, "No, I don't want to
open that in my mind."
She was like, "No, no, no."
And she -- I was like, "No."
She's like, "Okay."
So she starts reading it to me
on the phone.
-Yeah. If it's Oprah,
what are you going to say?
-You got to listen to it.
You want Oprah to read anything
to you.
-Anything to you at all, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It is fantastic.
You got to see this movie.
The story behind it is
even cooler.
This is a screenplay
that you wrote 27 years ago.
-27 years ago. Yeah.
26 years old, broke, struggling.
And I snuck into a play,
a theater in Atlanta
called the Alliance Theatre,
and August Wilson was having
a play called
"Two Trains Running."
-August Wilson?
-Yeah, and I got a chance
to talk to him,
and I had nothing,
and he was really encouraging.
And he told me to go write
what was in my heart.
And I went home and "Jazzman"
started to pour out then.
-Yeah. And did you think that
you were going to be
in the movie?
-Yeah, well, I had big dreams
even though I was broke.
Yeah, I wanted to be the lead.
Nobody knew my name.
But I wanted Will Smith
to play the co-lead.
Diana Ross, Halle Berry,
I wanted all these people
in the movie.
-Wow.
-But I aged out.
'Cause it starts
when he's 17 years old,
and even though I try to look
my best, I can't pull off 17.
Not even with digital Botox
you can't pull that off.
[ Laughter ]
So I found an incredible cast.
And Debbie Allen
did the choreography
and Terry Fletcher
did the music.
-I love Debbie Allen.
-It's really phenomenal.
-Can you tell everyone
what the film is about?
-It's about two star-crossed
lovers who find themselves
in very difficult situations,
set in the 1940s,
and all these obstacles
against them,
trying to keep their love apart.
But no matter what happens,
they always seem to find
each other again.
So it's a powerful,
powerful film.
-Yeah, it's beautiful.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a scene from Tyler
Perry's "A Jazzman's Blues."
Take a look at this.
[ Jazz music playing ]
-♪ Let the good times roll ♪
♪ Don't carry your load ♪
♪ Get together and let
the good times roll ♪
♪♪
♪ No matter what, it's rainy
weather, birds of a feather ♪
♪ Got to stick together ♪
♪ So get yourself
under control ♪
♪ Go out and get together
and let the good times roll ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How y'all doing?
Y'all alright?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, come on.
It's a different --
-Totally different.
-It's a departure for you, but I
love that you keep doing this.
And this is the one that
kind of got you started.
This is -- Congrats on
the fantastic reviews.
Who are those --
There's some new faces there.
-Amirah Vann.
Austin Scott was in that clip.
And Milauna Jackson.
And Solea Pfeiffer and Joshua
Boone, they lead the movie.
And all new faces that are
incredibly talented
that I'm excited about.
-Thank you for
doing all this stuff.
And, dude,
congrats on everything.
-Thank you.
-It's a great movie.
Tyler Perry, everybody.
"A Jazzman's Blues" premieres
tomorrow on Netflix.